madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues
aboutissement attendu du point de vue
institutionnel compte tenu de la
configuration de notre Assemblée
désormais ces motion censure sont une
somme de regret que je voudrais exprimer
ici au nom de mon groupe
oui nous avons des regrets notre premier
regret celui
n'avoir jamais pu pleinement examiner et
voter ce texte en première lecture alors
que les deux semaines prévues suffisait
à le faire chers collègues de
l'opposition en dépit des règles de
fair-play parlementaire et plus encore
de toute vertu démocratique vous avez
décidé de détourner notre règlement pour
créer une embolie parlementaire motion
prise de parole identique à répétition
comportement emprunt d'une forte
violence symbolique rappelle au
règlement et surtout plus de 20 000
amendements vous avez fait feu de tout
bois pour empêcher la tenue de nos
débats
tout cela dans un seul but empêcher le
débat et l'adoption même partielle de ce
texte en transformant l'Assemblée en un
véritable cirque qui fait honte à notre
institution avec
la présence pour finir
d'un responsable politique dans les
tribunes surveillant ces troupes comme
un empereur romain je n'ose imaginer ce
que serait une sixième république celle
que vous appelez de vos vœux
les députés du groupe démocrate aurait
voulu avoir le temps de présenter leur
point de vue qui nous semblait
équilibrer entre la nécessaire
responsabilité financière et l'objectif
de justice sociale vous nous avez privé
de ce débat et d'un véritable vote et je
le regrette amèrement parce que je sais
que dans l'intérêt des Français nous
aurions pu ensemble améliorer le texte
heureusement notre dialogue permanent
avec les sénateurs et notamment nos
cousins de l'Union centriste nous a
permis de défendre une large partie de
nos propositions et d'en faire adopter
un certain nombre Sénats puis en
commission mixte paritaire je voudrais
les remercier pour le travail que nous
avons su faire ensemble je crois même
pouvoir dire que ce travail en commun
illustre bien ce qu'est le centrisme
loin de l'intransigence dont font preuve
aujourd'hui certains qui sont réclamment
coeur mais l'ont en vérité abandonné
depuis de très nombreuses années
je voudrais aussi souligner la qualité
de nos échanges avec le gouvernement
même si toutes nos propositions n'ont
pas été reprises notamment celles
concernant le financement
notre second regret et le manque de
responsabilité de certaines oppositions
je ne parle pas de celles qui n'avait
pas de projet si ce n'est de se cacher
derrière une forme de respectabilité
pour déposer à la fin une motion de
censure en espérant que personne ne
remarquerait leur absence de
propositions je ne parle pas non plus de
ceux qui ont défendu et voté en son
temps 2013 une réforme qui amenait les
Français à dépasser de plus d'un an
l'âge légal de 62 ans sans le dire
honnêtement et qui défendent aujourd'hui
des propositions totalement illusoires
se raccrochant 60 ans croyant retrouvé
par ce totem les grandeurs de 1981 et
oubliant les grades difficultés qui ont
suivi cette parenthèse enchantée
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas d'illusion pour cela même si
j'espère que nos concitoyens ne se
laisseront pas berner par ces mirages
je parle en particulier de l'opposition
qui avait promis depuis des années de
faire cette réforme des retraites c'est
la même que le gouvernement a défendu en
atténuant l'âge de départ par rapport
aux promesses de la candidate soutenu
l'année dernière par les par pays mort
la peur le jeu de billard les jeux de
billard à trois bandes et malgré tous
les efforts du gouvernement fait à votre
endroit vous n'avez pas voulu afficher
par un vol clair vos positions
divergence sur ce sujet qui aurait dû
nous rassembler même si je sais que
certains collègues du groupe les
républicains voulaient en responsabilité
votez ce texte
issu d'un compromis après un travail
sérieux et juste
nous voulions très majoritairement
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
aller au vote que ce texte après
peut-être pour certaines et certains des
doutes mais surtout avec la conviction
que cette loi a été nécessaire et utile
nous prenons un de la décision qui a été
prise de déclencher la procédure prévue
par la Linéa 3 de l'article 49 de notre
Constitution cet outil existe il permet
aux forces politiques qui sont contre ce
texte de le rejeter si elles sont
majoritaires
certains à cette tribune parlent de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement comme un déni de démocratie
à mon sens c'est bien plus le
comportement de vos autres dans les mots
comme dans les actes qui frisent le déni
démocratie je voudrais d'ailleurs
rappeler que la queue de la violence
verbale ou symbolique à la violence
physique il y a souvent qui me parle
hop alors alors le groupe démocrate
alors le groupe démocrate prend acte
[Musique]
1 de cette inconscience acte de l'esprit
de responsabilité de responsabilité qui
anime le gouvernement et vous l'aurez
compris bien sûr soutenant le
gouvernement et persuadé de la nécessité
d'une réforme pour pérenniser notre
système de retraite nous ne voterons pas
cette censure mais il y aura un après et
de toute crise nous devons tirer des
leçons réfléchir au fond et à la méthode
ce que nous souhaitons profondément au
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]